silently passing through the inky void
of space a vessel was hurriedly making
its way towards its destination the
craft was Sleek designed and built by
hands not of this world aboard one of
the occupants knelt before its Elders it
was time it gathered its Arsenal in a
methodical almost ceremonial fashion its
spear latched onto its back with its
survival gear a medic kit containing
surgical equipment and specialized
serums it donned its gauntlets and
reached for the final piece its mask
that it slipped over its face ready for
its task the creature boarded a smaller
Scout ship which was jettisoned and
began to descend toward the planet below
a world known as Earth on the surface of
the planet itself a technician was
sitting at his desk boards staring at
readouts from satellites and the endless
sweeping of a radar scanning the skies
above for any signs of disturbance for a
moment as the Scout craft passed through
the atmosphere something happened that
broke the technician out of his boredom
there was a blip on the radar the tiny
detection of an unknown signal that of
an object traveling on a direct course
through the sky just as the technician
started to take notice the approaching
ship activated a stealth mechanism
reflecting all light away from it in
order to render it almost invisible
while simultaneously becoming
undetectable to radar the blip vanished
from the screen and didn't reappear the
technician Shrugged thinking it was
probably nothing but an equipment glitch
besides the SCP Foundation didn't pay
him enough to follow up on every tiny
blend a few hours later and several
continents away a mobile task force was
on an assignment the oppressive heat and
humidity of the wakandan Jungle was
bearing down on them especially in their
combat gear the operatives were all
feeling unbearably hot the foundation
researchers overseeing the mtf's mission
via satellite didn't have to contend
with the elements in the comfort of
their air-conditioned
but little did they or their boots on
the ground no there was something else
visiting the rainforest too it had been
stalking the squad for a few miles now
and not one of them had noticed just as
the creature planned a trio of red laser
beans cast three distinct dots over one
of the MTF operatives chest suddenly a
streak of energy shot through the air
crackling as it struck the agent tearing
through his chest and killing him on the
spot instinctively the remaining troops
turned and opened fire at the treetop
where the blast had come from spraying a
volley of bullets enough to start
shredding the wood of the tree splinters
and bark rang down they hit nothing
there was no sign of whoever or whatever
had fired that shot and killed their
teammate from behind them a pair of
discs with a row of long fan-like blades
around their Edge flew through the air
there was so much force behind the arm
that threw them that the pair of
shuriken lifted two of the remaining MTF
soldiers off their feet and impaled them
to the trunks of nearby trees the last
remaining Foundation operative looked at
the bodies of his dead Squad mates in
horror before turning and fleeing but
just as he ran for his life something
caught him it was transparent cloaked
and near impossible to see but it had
plunged a pair of blades into the MTF
trooper's chest lifting him off his feet
with ease as he screamed in pain an
invisible leathery-skinned hand reached
for his throat and twisted and in an
instant with a sickening crack the man
was silent and dropped limply to the
floor from the command center watching
an oz this imperceptible monster tore
through four of their finest operatives
with ease a pair of researchers turned
to look at each other the Expressions
they both wore were were faces of sheer
disbelief they both had heard stories
instantly recognizing the destructive
Behavior but never thought they'd see or
not see it carried out for real we still
don't have a name for them do we
researcher Hall asked has the pair of
them walked bristly down the corridor ah
negative reply lightest counterpart
researcher D ligirio that the files we
acquired for military intelligence
suggests they've been coming to Earth
for decades centuries even the earliest
known encounter took place in the 1700s
can we negotiate with this one at all
Paul asked fully expecting the answer I
don't think they respond well to that
kind of Engagement delegirio said they
seem to come to Earth with One Singular
purpose to hunt for sport well it seems
so uh what about their capabilities the
senior researcher pressed their
technology is pretty Advanced even
compared to some of the things we've
seen the other explained on top of that
they're fast strong and completely
ruthless pretty much an apex predator
according to Intel the instances of
these creatures that have previously
visited Earth have displayed a sort of
tribal nature fair to elaborate palprobe
based on the files their hunts seem
partially recreational but also like
some kind of ritual to prove themselves
as capable or to challenge themselves
that gives me an idea there's researcher
replied contact containment area 25b if
we play this right we can bag one of
these creatures and bring it in for
testing time seemed to race by as
Holland de ligurio were bundled aboard a
transport and taken directly to
containment area 25b a facility built by
the foundation specifically to house a
particularly dangerous anomaly within
the hour the two researchers were
standing facing a huge Stone Cube its
dark surface sporting a number of
symbols engraved into it growing
impatient knowing their window of
opportunity was rapidly closing all
turned to one of the foundation
Personnel station within the primary
containment Zone around
scp-076 Play It Again be instructed wake
him up hitting a button a recorded
message began to play over the
facilities loudspeakers it had been
translated into an ancient Sumerian
dialect that the entity within the stone
Cube had historically shown a preference
for come on out the message stated we
know you don't think any of us are worth
your time but we remember
omega-7 you agreed to work with us
before even though you don't think we
present enough of a challenge to you but
we may have found something that will an
adversary that you could have the
privilege of besting in combat there was
a brief moment of silence before the
stone began to rumble the security
Personnel on site tends to ripping their
weapons shakily nervous hands slowly the
circular lock on the side of the cube
began twisting the door had kept sealed
beginning to open are you sure we can do
this how Asti ligurio that's cp076 isn't
willing to cooperate this could go south
real quickly and God forbid what if
somebody found out what we're having him
do Hall didn't answer instead watching
us the door to the cube finally opened
and the lean man in his late 20s stepped
out his gray eyes stared out of a mess
of jet black hair his body adorned with
tattoos of Arcane runes and occult
imagery the sneering faces of demons
over his olive skin as the guards around
him nervously raised their weapons at
the ready
scp-076-2 casually strolled up to
researcher Hall until the two were
inches away from each other where Gable
asked fitting him with a Communications
earpiece and having him board a
transport Abel was sent directly towards
the last known coordinates of the now
deceased MTF deep in the heart of the
lakandan Jungle sat atop a tree as the
aircraft made its approach the creature
had lowered its cloaking device certain
it was alone as it polished a skull it
had collected from one of the ill-fated
operatives the Predator was a member of
a species known as the yacha one of the
few details about its race that
delegurios files hadn't mentioned
everything else was accurate though it
was indeed a hunter here to claim
trophies as proof of its skill these
trophies happen to be the skulls and
spines of whatever it killed hearing the
sound of an incoming vehicle the
Predator instinctively reached for a
control on its left wrist Gauntlet its
cloaking device reactivated bending the
light away from its self to render the
alien Hunter nearly invisible through
the lenses of its biomask the Predator
watched The Craft pass overhead and the
shape of a single humanoid Heat
Signature dropping from it and landing
in the rain forest trekking through the
Lush vegetation Abel walked towards the
location he had been given it always
irked The Immortal barbarian when the
foundation attempted to use him to
perform their menial Dirty Work to Able
such tasks were beneath him but he had
been promised to fight with a worthy
adversary and that was the only reason
he had agreed to undertake this Mission
looking around as he reached a clearing
there was no sign of the MTF agents
until that is Abel craned his neck
upwards and found them something had
meticulously gathered up the bodies and
hung them from the branches by their
legs it felt distinctly like a warning
as well as a taunting gloat every
indicator pointed to this being the
action of a creature that was marking
its Newfound territory with a wave of
his hand Abel pulled a black edge sword
out of a pocket mentioned holding his
weapons and held the blade at the ready
looking down he saw three points of red
light had appeared on his bare chest
just as Abel caught side of the Treetops
where the lasers were coming from a bolt
of high energy plasma was fired towards
him within the same Split Second he
hurled his sword in the direction of his
invisible enemy the blast struck him and
knocked him down searing his flesh not
that Abel could feel pain at the same
time his sword spun through the air and
cleaved through the branch where the
Predator had been perched causing the
creature to drop to the Jungle floor
with a thud as the yacht just stood up
he noticed its Gauntlet was sparking
having sustained damage in the fall now
its cloaking device was flickering on
and off the Predator knew it would need
to repair its equipment but first and
foremost he needed to collect a trophy
from its latest kill the creature Strode
towards where Abel was laying a Scorch
Mark left by the plasma Caster burned
into his flesh its cloaking device still
malfunctioning the hunter reached down
to claim its prize Abel's eyes suddenly
snapped open and comp creature by
surprise reeling his leg back he
delivered a sharp kick that sent the
Predator hurling backwards despite it
being well over seven feet tall and 520
pounds of armor and alien muscle Abel
hardly stood back up facing off against
the alien Warrior as it too Drew itself
to full height The Gauntlet on its left
wrist continued to spit Sparks until the
Predator reached a clawed digit over and
pressed to control with an electronic
beep its cloak deactivated fully and the
hunter was revealed who was tall
standing on two legs like a man it
seemed life and agile but clearly almost
as strong as Abel himself judging by how
muscular it was long appendages
resembling locks of hair protruded from
its head behind a metal faceplate a mass
covered the true face of the creature
below a clicking chittering noise
emanated from beneath the Predator's
biomass as it reached for a sash that
went across its front and produced a
pair of small metal circles Abel flexed
his shoulders and ran creature the
Predator hurled both its discs at Abel
curved blades extending from both of
them as they spun through the air able
ducked out of the path of one shuriken
narrowly dodging the second as he
charged the alien Hunter reaching for
its back the Predator produced The Long
ornate handle of its Combi stick both
ends of its telescopic spear extended
and the hunter began racing forward to
clash head-on with its Newfound prey it
plunged the spear right through Abel
with all its strength lifting the
Barbarian off his feet on the end of its
weapon out of nowhere
scp-076 produced another of his swords
the Predator turning to look in
confusion at the weapon that had
seemingly just appeared in the hand of
what it had taken for an ordinary human
catching the off-world Game Hunter by
surprise Abel swept the sword through
the air cleaving the creature's spear in
two causing him to drop back to the
ground landing on his feet following it
with a second Swift swing of his blade
Abel brought the weapon down on a slash
that cut across the creature's
it sliced through the thick reptilian
hide of the Predator leaving a streak of
fluorescent green blood oozing from its
torso the creature roared in pain it
sounded like a call of a lion echoing
through the trees in retaliation the
Predator extended a pair of blades
contained in its right Gauntlet and
swipe them at able the wrist blades
nearly missed his face as he dodged in
incoming attack only to be caught by the
creature's other hand it gripped his
head and plunged downwards knocking Abel
over and sending him face first into the
rainforest floor reaching for his
cloaking device control the Predator
disappeared retreating into the jungle
to tend to its heavily bleeding wound
what manner of devil is this creature
Hall Abel yelled at the researcher over
his earpiece hacking branches out of his
path with his sword as he followed the
trail of luminous green left by the
wounded Hunter it's a warrior From
Another World Paul replied a hunter that
tracks its prey by their body heat
considers itself honorable but often
likes to go after more dangerous targets
to challenge itself not unlike you Abel
I am nothing like this demon the
Barbarian shouted in Fury this gutless
monster has no honor if it did it would
not give itself such an unfair Advantage
nor would it run away when wounded a
true warrior would be happy to die a
Wario's death in single combat and would
not rely on all its fancy Weaponry well
from what we can tell these things have
their own codes of sorts diligiria's
voice said over the comms you might not
think of this Hunter as honorable but it
definitely thinks of itself that way
maybe use that to your advantage I do
not need to be lectured by the likes of
you able interrupted you have not known
the heat of battle none of you at the
foundation have I will follow the trail
of this cowardly BEAST's blood and
cleave its foul head from its shoulders
unbeknownst to Abel high above a branch
the Predator was watching him its
biomass had been zoomed in on him the
hunter listening to the barbarian's
outrage it turned to the task at hand
opening up its Medi kit and producing
the surgical tools within intended to
the Deep green cut across its chest
stifling Roars of pain beneath its Mask
The Predator stapled the injury closed
and applied a solvent to cauterize it
night was beginning to fall and Abel had
long since lost the trail of green blood
frustrated he thought back to what the
puny researchers at the foundation had
told him of his alien adversary if it
believed itself to be honorable to have
a code then perhaps using that to lure
it out to face him might work with the
sun rapidly disappearing beyond the tree
line Abel gathered a number of branches
hacking them off trees with his sword
and fashioning them into burning torches
he placed them in a circle around the
circumference of a clearing creating a
makeshift gladiatorial Arena he could
feel his blood boiling the urge to
defeat this monster making him sieve
throwing his head back and beating a
fist against his chest Abel roared up at
the dark sky come out Hunter yeah
show yourself come on do it I'm right
here watching him from afar hidden by
its cloak the Predator recognized what
was happening this was a challenge a
direct call to engage in single combat
refusing this Challenge and shooting its
prey dead would be quicker easier but
the hunter knew it was being watched and
therefore judged with a growl it dropped
to the ground and paced towards the
circle Abel turned as the Predator
revealed itself appearing almost from
thin air as it did he drew one of his
weapons and stood ready to fight the
hunter Shrugged off the technology it
carried on its back dropping the plasma
caster and its Medicaid before reaching
up and pulling off its mask its face was
grotesque four hooked mandibles
surrounding its mouth flared in Anger
you are one
ugly Abel said only to be interrupted by
the Predator extending the blades from
its Gauntlet and letting out another
beastial Roar holding his sword Aloft
Abel gave a goading back into his
opponent as the pair of them circled one
another finally the creature gave in and
lunched at him swiping its pair of razor
sharp serrated blades at able he swung
his sword and at the last second
deflected the oncoming blow with a clang
of metal reaching into his pocket
Dimension Abel pulled a second weapon
out in his other hand and swiped at the
Predator slicing through the creature's
hide and leaving another gaping wound at
its thigh roaring in Fury the Predator
launched another strike able blocked the
attack yet again this time by Crossing
his swords but the Predator barged
forward driving its blades into the
prey's chest and pinning his two weapons
against him the Monstrous alien
viciously head-butted Abel the hooks of
its mandible scratching his face as it
did before reaching up to the back of
his neck with its free hand Abel could
feel the sheer strength of the hunter
lifting him off his feet ready to twist
his neck and pull his head off to claim
it as a trophy kicking the predator in
the chest able used the force of the
impact to push himself free from the
creature's grip backflipping through the
air and Landing a few feet away his
swords clattered together as they
dropped to the ground The Immortal
barbarians summoning another and
immediately charging at the Predator it
had been winded by the kick and barely
recovered in time to defend itself as
the blade swung for its neck the
Predator staggered back green blood
oozing from its hide and pouring from
its mouth that blow had mortally wounded
it it was bleeding heavily and knew it
might not survive this hunt but it
refused to be vested by a human even one
as seemingly invulnerable as able
hunching over listening to him slowly
approaching to deliver the killing blow
the Predator tapped a series of controls
on its Gauntlet a gradually accelerating
beeping began emanating from the device
turning around at the last second the
alien Hunter impaled Abel before he was
upon it skewering
scp-076-2 on its wrist blades his sword
had been raised above his head to plunge
through the creature and even while
impaled Abel was able to deliver the
final blow stabbing the Predator while
it too had stabbed him the pair were
locked in his stalemate angrily roaring
each other until an explosion of energy
bursts from the Hunter's gauntlets
reducing both Abel and the Predator to
atoms watching from their satellite feed
Hall and diligirio's side they wouldn't
have their specimen for testing but at
least they knew that Abel would
eventually resurrect within the stone
cube of
scp-076-1 but even higher up than their
satellite someone else was watching a
group of predators growled and chittered
amongst themselves having witnessed from
their ship as one of their own had died
in a battle with Abel although there was
no way of knowing the noises The Hunting
Party were making could have been
expressions of disappointment at their
fallen brother or a declaration of war
now for another murderous matchup
between one of the foundation's most
infamous anomalies and another science
fiction Legend go and check out Boba
Fett vs scp-610 the flesh that hates and
afterwards witness a battle between two
brothers in scp-073 and scp-076 Kane
versus able